[Musique]
le constat était frappant le mois
dernier
je Audrey bogmans déclare avec 41
nouveaux élus on compte beaucoup de
néophyte de la politique
c'est dans un restaurant de sa
circonscription qu'on rencontre la
nouvelle députée d'Iberville Audrey
merci moi j'ai eu la chance de parler
avec Audrey avant la campagne électorale
parce qu'aurait se poser des questions
j'ai des enfants mon conjoint ma famille
alors moi j'avais comme mandat d'appeler
Audry pour répondre à ces questions
parce qu'elle manquait de temps pour
prendre toutes ces recrues par la main
lac les a jumelées avec ses ténors pour
leur expliquer la vie parlementaire il
faut comprendre que le rôle on joue et
c'est ce qui est plus difficile pour
certaines personnes il y en a ils
comprennent jamais des députés plantes
vertes comme moi là
depuis deux ans l'ex député éclaire sans
son par exemple ne l'a pas compris son
rôle durant le dernier mandat
croissylvie d'amour la marque là c'est
dans ton compte il faut que tu la fasses
donc n'importe quel emploi je pense
qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent se dédier
puis faire la différence puis dans
d'autres qui peuvent s'asseoir puis
profiter
du bateau
je pense pas qu'il y en a d'autres qui
rame Audrey ne sera jamais une plante
verte
point rire c'est de se départir des
actions de son entreprise une ferme
familiale obligation de la commissaire à
l'éthique avec mes parents mon mari mes
sœurs ont été élevés dans cette
entreprise là donc c'est sûr que ça
donne une valeur sentimentale au-delà de
la valeur monétaire puis c'est un
détachement de dire je la mets de côté
pour être capable d'être député
Sylvie d'amour là aussi vécu comme
agricultrice un domaine que les deux
femmes maîtrisent mais dont elles ne
pourront jamais débattre au Parlement
pour éviter les conflits d'intérêts
un peu moins puis on se voit à
l'Assemblée nationale
ça fait
[Musique]
pour les aider à apprivoiser tous ces
changements dans leur vie l'Assemblée
nationale a appelé du renfort la
première chose qu'on apprend en devenant
député c'est qu'on pensait qu'on savait
mais en fait on ne sait rien comme le
dernier mandat a été marqué par
l'anxiété et la détresse de certains
députés durant la pandémie plusieurs ont
aussi connu des problèmes de sécurité
des élus sortant ont levé la main pour
donner leur conseil aux nouveaux une
formation avec les familles qui
n'existaient pas auparavant
[Musique]
Andrea Morin fait partie des 10 nouveaux
visages aux parties
procureur a vécu un baptême de feu avec
la controverse entourant l’exclusion de
sa collègue Marie-Claude Nicole et la
démission de sa chef la controverse ça
commencerait
ça nous a préparé pour les aléas de la
politique mais bon ça vous a pas
découragé la du tout là-bas vous vous
retrouvez devant suivre une ligne de
partie est-ce que vous êtes à l'aise
avec ça
il y a pas de souci de toute façon il
faut savoir aussi qu'une ligne de partie
mais quand on est entre nous on a quand
même des bonnes discussions
amusez-vous quand même
ça c'est bien important
si jumeaux de 8 ans et sa petite de
trois ans ce matin
avant de rejoindre Samantha à Québec
[Musique]
sa nouvelle photo de famille c'est celle
de son parti politique pour les quatre
prochaines années ici Véronique prince
Radio-Canada Québec